how often have people with
open marriages have been in your office
well let's see and this is one of those
like
from a research perspective this would
be flawed because I see the they're in
my office because their marriage is
falling apart yeah so there may be lots
of people
having open relationships that don't end
up in a divorce lawyer's office so I'd
never meet them but I meet a lot of
people that that was the Hail Mary pass
sure like I meet a lot of people that
they tried that but it in retrospect it
was a Hail Mary pass it was like uh look
we've just figured let's try this you
know like maybe it's maybe this will
this will keep the glue together on this
thing you know and and
um and I've also seen open open
relationships go wrong
you know where we agree we're just gonna
have sexual connections with other
people or we're going to bring other
people into the bedroom
um but together like we're going to be
together with other people or with
another person and then there that
connection of those two people
like do you think it's a soul mate all
of a sudden now and it goes in this
other because and again is that novelty
is that like it's the reason why I don't
understand why people have threesomes
it's kind of like
you know when someone sings to you I
don't know where to look
like I don't know where to look like if
someone's singing to me I don't know
where to look like it feels weird right
like this is a conundrum no this
I'll say this too this will never but I
it's the reason I can't go to strip
clubs yeah I don't know where to look
like if I go to strip club you know like
you go to strip club and and there's you
know the part where they the woman's on
the stage and she walks past each person
just does a little thing and then next
person and the next little thing
so when she's right in front of you
I like a woman's face and I like a
woman's body I like both of them so I'm
looking at the woman's face and she's
very beautiful but she's naked and I
think oh she's naked I should be looking
at her naked body because obviously
that's like it's almost rude not to
because she's naked in front of me of
course so then I'm looking at her naked
body which is lovely to look at but then
I find myself going oh my God you're
just still like you should look at her
face for God's sake yeah and then I look
at her face and find myself having this
whole thing in my head where I'm going
like oh my God where am I supposed to
look so I think a threesome with
two women you don't hardly know or
you're not that's different
but a threesome with a long-term partner
where you're in a relationship with and
a new person
seems to me a very dangerous ground
because you're going to want to enjoy
the novelty of this new person but
you're gonna have to spend time with
this person after
so how much attention do you spend to
the new novel exciting thing without
creating the impression that you don't
you're not interested in this because
you want you're my favorite person but
this is fun so I want to just try this
for a few but then also I don't want to
forget about that like it it just seems
tricky that analogy by the way is
brilliant and also I guess it's tricky
because the consequences of mistakes are
quite High because you're gonna have to
talk about it right and there's a
there's an easy way to misinterpret the
data right like so if I'm
if I really like sleeping with my
partner but I get one chance to sleep
with this other person like well of
course I should indulge in that because
I can do this anytime like what it you
know but but this person my partner
might interpret that as oh so you're
more interested in her than me because
that voice in in my partner that would
be you know insecure might hear that you
know so I I just why would you even why
would you open yourself up to that level
of chaos you seem to love chess in the
courtrooms it's a kind of uh intimate
human chess of sorts yeah no that's
that's too high risk how do we get on
threesomes oh open open marriages well
we got how do we get on threesomes I
don't know I always wondering how people
get into threesomes
um I figure they like if one is fun two
must be better if two is better three
must be better
um yeah I I think we we the way that
that this becomes an issue is
why would you have a non-monogamous
relationship
what is it about your sex life with this
person that's not satisfying and I think
that that is the question that's harder
to ask yourself and to try to answer
with your partner